bonsoir
comment ça va tirer quoi les breaks
pourquoi prend 10 minutes pour lire le
bouquin
honnêteté intellectuelle avant toi ça
commence bien comment valou très bien
très très bien et comment va bébé très
bien et bel où
il va bien
bb c'est le surnom bbc ont le surnom de
marica 1 c'est ça voilà et loup c'est
votre surnom alors grégory basso vous
avez été l'été dernier sur tf1 greg le
millionnaire le héros de l'émission de
télé réalité qui a battu tous les scores
d'audience durant deux mois est nommé
truelle d'or
samuel adore c'est mieux alors le
principe de l'émission c'est un faux
millionnaire dont qui invite 20 filles
dans sa villa de rêve à ibiza pour
choisir la femme de sa vie ce qu'elles
ne savent pas c'est que cet homme n'est
pas millionnaire mais masson et c'est
vous donc maïka que que greg a choisi en
fait le seul vrai millionnaires dans
toute cette affaire sérieusement c'est
gérard louvin non chef lui demandé j'ai
pas vu l'état de son compte jusqu'à
présent serait dans ce cas je lui
souhaite ouais c'est une émission de
télé réglages et institutions c'est
interdit la télé en prison
oui c'est ça oui c'est un mec grèce
devant lui qui choisit une bonne
l'aguiché puisqu'on a découvert ce soir
c'est que le fils de depardieu bon voilà
le tour de france je te raconte pas et
tf1 la télévision voilà où ça en est les
gens sont déçus
alors page 57
incroyable qu'un grec si tu veux lire
vas-y un passage bien bon vassal et greg
le millionnaire salé imaginez qu'on vous
ait proposé de faire grève le
polytechnicien c'est un peu plus
difficile est réglo coup de boule et
c'est vrai qu'on fait mal crois que vous
êtes un millionnaire pauvres chez
pakistan dans ce
parce que c'est ça non mais pendant
l'émission je
m'en fichais tous est cet argent cette
maison cette voiture
vous avez vous tué sortir la poubelle
vous l'avez vu tout de suite que c'était
pas un vrai millionnaire non gvg page
est pas prêté vraiment attention en fait
j'ai découvert cette personne comme
comme une autre comme ça
alors ce qui est génial avec vous dans
cette histoire c'est bien entendu vous
étiez de mèche avec tf1 pour mentir aux
filles pour leur faire croire que vous
étiez millionnaire risque est encore
plus drôle si vous avez menti à tf1
c'est dommage ça extraordinaire c'est
dire que mam il y avait un mensonge dans
le mensonge
je leur avais victoire blanc avait fait
croire que vous étiez masson et vous
avez oublié de leur expliquer que vous
aviez fait de la taule quoi oui
évidemment ça fait un scandale parce
qu'il pouvait pas appeler l'émission
greg craig le dealer il m'aime
et le missionnaire elle avait pensé au
parloir mais bon et puis après ils ont
découvert vous aviez fait des films
pornos soit peut être greg les ardeurs
mais enfin tout ceci n'est jamais eu de
film porno une équipe de charme ouais on
va en parler troisième sujet polémique
la fameuse marjolaine qu'on a retrouvée
morte
troisième problème donc la fameuse
marjolaine la candidate asiatique tu te
souviens pas de marjolaine ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils sont soumis oui oui
non mais j'ai vu des zappings des trucs
que tu lui dis c'est ferme ta gueule qui
fout la merde et offert la marjolaine
qui a déclaré que vous étiez homosexuels
je pense qu'il est mieux placé que
quiconque pour savoir que cette prime
car
attention là parce que vous avez dit que
je retourne à marjolaine c'est pas très
bien vous avez dit qu'il s'était rien
passé je n'avais rien fait ouais
ce sont des appels facturés mais c'est
quand même intéressant de faire du
pognon ouais non scientifique
alors greg grégory basso pour rétablir
la vérité pour établir votre vérité vous
avez décidé d'écrire un livre
autobiographique aux éditions robert
laffont qui s'appelle main véritable
histoire voilà greg le millionnaire sera
quand
alors ça commence évidemment sur le
mensonge et sur le flip qui s'ensuit
vous êtes sur le point de partir à ibiza
pour retrouver ses vingt jeunes filles
dans cette sublime villa de rêve ne vous
n'êtes pas heureux il pas heureux car
vous n'avez pas fourni à tf1 votre
casier judiciaire où figurent les 50
tonnes auxquelles vous avez été condamné
pour trafic de drogue décidément c'est
sincère alors ce qui me fait rire c'est
d'avoir cette société complètement vers
l'est en fait quoi je veux non mais je
pense que
ça arrive à pas mal de monde je crois
qu'il ya pas mal de monde aussi dans le
sud disent à qui c'est arrivé vos
premiers démêlés avec la justice
remontent à la classe de terminale
grégory c'est ce que vous racontez dans
votre livre quand gantés cagoulés vous
conduisait un camion plein d'ordinateurs
volés et vous faites attraper parce que
vous êtes dans une station service et
vous payez avec un chèque volé là vous
aviez piquer les ordinateurs c'est ça
j'ai une longue j'ai une longue période
j'étais très con way je serais pas allé
en prison je crois mais si je ne me
serais pas déjà les frites 12 mois
et
heureusement ça finit bien
vous avez 12 mois avec sursis quand même
ça c'est que j'ai passé mon bac et que
j'étais plutôt bon élève à ce moment là
ils m'ont ils ont été assez gentil 12
mois avec sursis peut-être qu'ils
auraient dû être qu'ils auraient dû être
un peu plus dur maintenant avec du recul
ça me gêne c'est ce que j'essaie de dire
tout à l'heure à guillaume c'est à dire
ce que je n'ai si son père avait été un
petit peu plus dur avec lui peut-être
qu'il y avait moins de conneries dans
une claque dans ta gueule ça c'est notre
vie on récupère
alors ensuite vous découvrez les rêves
puis l'ecstasy et vous consommez jusqu'à
25 ecsta en un week-end c'est beaucoup
quand même non
à nous de france
télé la cité plus trop plus trop moi
même j'étais plutôt capable d'aller
m'entraîner
bien plus qu'un studio de moyens ouais
c'était pas que j'avais des extras qui
est aussi les hassidim aussi la coke
enfin j'ai bien chargé un moment quand
même un moment vous en prenez trop fait
un mauvais trip vous êtes prêt de
l'acide en présence d'un chat et le chat
devient fou quoi non ça c'est moi oui
c'est toi
c'est pour ça c'est qu'à force de lire
des livres de drogués si tu veux
à force de lire des livres de drogués je
sais toi nous sommes devenus fous
ben oui lieu j'ai pas devenu fou il a
décidé à un moment j'ai un nom
il a décidé à moi il s'est dit il faut
que j'arrête d'en prendre faut que j'en
vendent non non c'est pas venu comme ça
en fait c'est venu à partir du moment où
j'ai commencé à vouloir payer meadows
c'est un engrenage on fait dans lequel
tu t'enfermes et qui serait plus qu'ils
s'arrêtent plus parce que t'es pas ce
qu'était pas t'as pas la force étape à
la tap à la che pas quant à la volonté
de tout arrêter t'as pas la volonté de
redevenir simple parce que tu es de
raisonnement dans un monde à part le
fait et les gens autour de toi sont
normaux et de critiquer essaye de te
faire comprendre que d'être montré que
tu deviens fou et tu t'en rends pas
compte tu t'en rends pas compte parce
que tu es dans un autre monde et voilà
alors bien c'est la belle vie quand même
parce que tu en faisais dans une boîte
c'est +3 versé une bouteille quand vous
partez en vacances c'est dans les îles
donc effectivement vous avez la bonne
amie et label'vie mais avec du recul
maintenant je me dis c'est une vie plus
ouais c'est je pensais à ce moment là
que c'était la belle vie ou mais je vois
ce que j'ai fait autour de moi un finish
et louvain intense et
bien en tous les cas à l'époque l'idée
que vous pouviez tuer des gens avec la
drogue que vous leur demandiez ça vous a
pas effleuré j'étais pages tapée acheter
inconscient ce type y voilà et puis un
jour tout bascule vous recevez un coup
de fil du chef dealer le patron du
réseau depuis la gendarmerie de valréas
ou en espagnol et il vous dit viens te
rendre
rien à voir là dedans je suis
séropositif monfils a le sida je suis
dans la mouise je suis dans la mouise
vient dire que j'ai rien à voir là
dedans viens te rendre et puis voilà
quoi et de la gendarmerie sous ça m'a
fait plaisir je me fais plaisir sur le
coup vous imaginez puis pendant deux
mois je suis resté en cavale j'ai fait
une [ __ ] en l'air plusieurs fois j'ai
vu mes parents qui étaient très
malheureux à ce moment là et pour la
première fois j'ai vu mon père avec les
larmes aux yeux puis j'ai décidé de
rentrer de venir vous êtes rendu oui là
vous comprenez que l'idée c'est de vous
faire porter le chapeau et tout le monde
doit importer tout frais tout le monde
balance tout le monde et vous ramassez
quand même la plus grosse peine cinq ans
ça calme ouais parce qu on pourrait
aussi penser que si vous avez pris la
plus grosse peine c'est parce que vous
étiez le plus coupable non pourrait on
peut dire ça toute manière c'est ce que
je disais moi personnellement on juge
donc quelque part quelque part je
pouvais pas me défendre mon avocat
pouvaient pas vraiment me défendre non
plus parce que je me mettais dans la
gueule du loup j'étais con
quand même à la faire ses 10000 ecsta 85
kg de cannabis et 300 grammes de cocaïne
je ne sais pas rien qu'en fait ils ont
regroupé deux affaires trois affaires le
cannabis on n'avait rien à voir là
dedans y avait un texte dans lequel on
n'avait rien à voir non plus il
représente quoi de trois jours de
consommation
donc la boue vous retrouver en taule
greg vous en profiter quand même offert
un moment une gamine qui passe une
dénommée sandrine qui vient vous voir au
parloir pendant un quart d'heure
voilà une gamine qui passe c'est une
fille que j'ai à vous je sais ça loire
le gardien se retourne pendant un quart
d'heure est appelée donne la fiole
vous lui faites un mot non c'était de
l'insémination artificielle un sérieux
oui j'ai pas si on peut vraiment appeler
ce qu'on a fait à ce moment là dans le
parloir faire l'amour pas se faire
l'amour celle de plus tendre que ça je
pense
mais bon on a fait ce qu'on a fait
de pauvres ça fait mouche
les panneaux mojawi cv ça faisait 14 à
14 mois et ceir et l'impression
donc cet enfant vous l'avez pas gardé
elle n'a pas voulu le dire n'a pas voulu
et on a bien fait voilà à la sortie de
prison vous n'êtes pas les cinq ans
parce que avec les remises de peine ou
en fait quand même beaucoup moins fait
deux ans et demi c'est sage en sortirons
conditionnelle ouais c'est ça et la
sortie vous dites pour quelqu'un comme
moi l'incarcération a été une bonne
chose ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai parce
que si j'avais pas été incarcérés si je
mettais pas fait arrêter chez pourri je
serais aujourd'hui ce qu'ils n'ont
peut-être en prison pour plus pour plus
peut-être dans les bas-fonds de je ne
sais quoi et ça m'a fait du bien quand
je suis sain je me défonce plus je suis
plus sain que les trois quarts des gens
que je connais maintenant ma drogue
c'est le sport comme c'était à l'époque
le vélo
ça m'a rendue plus ardue encore avec
système énervé contre 607,1 les plus
rebelles moi je pense qu'on peut rien
faire contre le système de toute façon
en france assez parle pour toi ouais tu
peux plus rien faire ah ouais j'suis pas
vendu mon âme au diable encore pas
encore
fait je pense pas peut-être que ses
citoyens vivent ainsi tu nous entends
les lecteurs quand l'on voit un intérêt
on s'entend de prison vous devenez
stripteaseur je suis élu je faisais du
strip j'ai fait des clips de charme
l'équipe érotique on à bonnes idées j'ai
jamais faite pour ne sais pas mais bon
et juste ce n'était pas désagréable
entre nous soit dit a tourné ce n'est
pas un métier si désagréable que ça ça
vous dégoûte un peu vous devenez partant
chez disney ouais
non mais ça ça fait rire les gens mais
les gens qui y ont
nettement ralenti parce qu'on a tous
fait des métiers de merde dans l'autre
on a des objets de tarzan avec un slip
léopard de tous les boulots que j'ai
fait jusqu'à présent c'était sur une
scène c'est celui qui sait celui dans
lequel je me suis le plus éclaté et
laissa pas mowgli dans la vie
c'est pas mal d'argent il faut revoir
cette petite armée dans la parade vous
pouvez vous croisez part dans le
mobile ces mamans légende c'est par le
cd fratrie
s'étend et jay z géniteur qui les
acrobates et alors c'est à cette époque
donc vous tourner un film porno alors
vous dites dans le livre que cet
incident le charme de érotique ouais
ouais alors déjà discuté mon chéri parce
que
vous dites c'était un clip de charge le
problème c'est que c'est sorti en vidéo
votre toit vous y trouveriez avec marco
s'est montrée mollahs surgelés vue oui
oui là-bas alors vous avez de mon sexe
quelque part oui j'avais vu une
pénétration non alors est ce qu'on peut
appeler ça du port nous non
reconnaissait le
clip de chars quid de charme mais c'est
l'entente cordiale beats et les deux
stars ben voilà c'est pas le porno et le
hard terminer la série à mercredi
attaquée au tribunal
est-ce que vous avez attaqué dans ceux
qui ont ressorti ce ce clip de charme
comme vous dites non parce que parce que
parce que je n'ai pas les os j'ai par
contre je vais attaquer les journaux qui
ont dit que j'avais fait du porno est
d'accord moi je ne dis pas que vous avez
fait départ d'audrey l'isard plus
rien
voilà donc pour connaître après la
prison ces petits boulots tout ça même
si tarzan c'était sympa vous êtes un peu
des primaires présence était de la
rétention de champion
c'était un peu déprimé comme le vélo
c'est ma préparation physique
attention ce qu'on vise ils préparent
leur tous les cas quand le casting de
tf1 arrive vous croyez plus en rien vous
vous défendez la tour infernale
vous pensé partir à l'étranger un à las
vegas comme ces petits êtres & gas wire
faire des couilles en or ce qui pourrait
lui dire voilà je restais parce que
sinon ça aurait pas été drôle cette
émission il dit vous voilà alors
heureusement une fois vous êtes enfermé
dans cette dans cette ville agisse a en
compagnie de ces charmantes jeunes
filles vous tombez sur marie qu'un ici
présentes à la première fois que vous la
voyez vous dites waouh
ah bon
c'est pas y être sensible mais
nous dit-elle rayonner noir y croire
aussi ça elle rayonnait vous dites c'est
la seule à exister auprès des autres ce
qui s'est passé c'est quand il ya eu la
première à la première rencontre c'est
vrai que c'est la première que j'ai
remarqué parce que parce que j'adore les
filles brune aux yeux clairs au terme at
et voilà et elle a une assez belle
silhouette de loi est magnifique je
pense même un tatouage sur le pied aussi
très beau et le piercing vous pouvez pas
imaginer où sa volonté lui demander
comme c'est son père qui fait des
piercings j'espère qu'il n'a pas fait un
endroit où je pense
marica rassurez moi
c'est plutôt le nombril et [ __ ]
c'est papa qui fait les celui qui a fait
le tatouage aussi
voilà donc quand vous la voyez vous dit
tout de suite s'est-elle quoi ça arrive
ça me fait toujours un bain ça le fait
toujours bien jamais un mot pour vos
euros elle n'était pas du nom et demi
pour critiquer des autres filles ni pour
ni pour ni pour me brancher d'ailleurs
pas ce que je vois c'est qu'elle allait
mettre en râteau la fête soit elle avait
compris tout de suite vous étiez pas
vraiment millionnaire j'ai sur le coeur
pudique et super discrète c'est un petit
peu le cas en fait sûr que soit
étrangère et pas mal de filles
apparemment qui avait découvert à cause
de quoi ils ont vu que vous étiez pas un
vrai millionnaire c'est ma grande gueule
je suppose l'accent peut-être non
l'accent à rennes avant tu peux être
millionnaire et du sud non c'est que
j'ai une grande gueule il faut le dire
et je suis impulsif et et j'ai la tête
je crois je me lâche je suis assez
naturellement plus qu'un millionnaire
mais tu les entendent pas souvent comme
ça en fait ça c'est ce que les filles me
disais après moi je pensait bien tenir
mon rôle et j'ai essayé en tout cas puis
j'ai laissé des indices un petit peu
aussi tout au long de l'émission parce
que ça le faisait ça me faisait flipper
bras les indices de justes il s'adonne
manque et tout ça en parlant de la
maison alors là j'étais avec elle en
aurait discuté alors quand il fallait
surtout pas lui dire ça mais si j'ai
fait ça mais ça c'est pas finot de
glisser que j'ai eu envie de me pendre à
tous le lendemain j'avais un peu peur de
sa réaction donc en fait oui à moudre
aux aviez peur qu'elle où vous avez
plein jour où elle découvre métier pas
un vrai millionnaire j'étais persuadé
c'est pas moi qui l'ait choisie c'est
elle qui va choisir la paix est en fait
vous vous étiez assez contente
d'apprendre qu'ils étaient pas vraiment
millionnaire pas ce que vous dites je
savais pas très bien comment on vit avec
un millionnaire ces charmantes ça ouais
je crois que je serai pas à l'aise avec
avec un mec est plein tube ouais les
repas où il faut pas bouger le golf tout
ça ça m'intéresse
les jours les autres c'est épouvantable
un nom on n'ira pas jusque là qu'un bon
alors marica vous n'avez pas été choqué
par le passé de grégory quand vous avez
appris
le clip de charme comme idi
stripteaseur gogo danseur la tôle les ex
tu as tout ça non pourquoi
j'ai pas
déjà jugé un père qui est un score
depuis 26 ans donc les mecs qu'on fait
de la taule moi j'en ai déjà à croiser
bah oui frappe de ses amis bon bah voilà
un vrai pote avec des taulards vous nous
dire là
il ya des gens qui se suicident chez eux
ouais mon père connaît pas mal de gens
qui ont fait de la taule la plupart de
ses amis menacé ça
dure voilà vous étiez en famille quoi et
pour moi le temps qu'on fait de la
présence pas forcément des gens qui sont
mauvais maintenant les gens qui sont
intelligents et qu'ils ont acquis ont
pris une leçon de ça pour moi c'est
des gens qui sont bien tout le moins
droit à l'erreur et puis il a payé sa
dette
merci à l'époque j'aimais beaucoup
sandrine aussi quand même erreur le
montage était assez justement
assez sympa est-ce que vous avez
envisagé de vivre à trois avec sandrine
apte à prendre
oui vous l'avez pas 100 mais n'a pas du
tout voir et marjolaine noël mais un
différend alors vous croyez aux signes
america vous vous dites greg est sorti
de prison le 2 mai 2000 et il m'a offert
ma bague le 2 mai 2003
vous pensez que ça c'est un signe
important c'est pas forcément sexuel moi
je consens c'est pas un signe du ciel
c'est
ouais donc l'incidence
de coïncidences aussi c'est qu'ils et à
revendre en cas disney et que votre père
son surnom c'est un fait ça pour vous
c'est important ça veut dire que ces
faits importants
un signe
votre tatouage présent que j'ai déjà des
spirales et sur l'anneau qui vous a
offert il des spirales aussi pour vous
c'est un signe ça non c'est pas assez
pas que c'est un signe je pars de rien
c'est qu'il ya plein de trucs qui ont
lieu des petites choses je suis sûr
qu'avec avec des amis vous avez des
points communs ou bien on a toujours
envie de partager des choses je trouvais
ça sympa qui les fait argent que mon
père son nom d'artiste soit argent
c'est pas des chine qui évoque pour vous
une prédestination être ensemble toute
votre vie quand même à la ville est
tellement longue je peux pas vous dire
si je vais rester toute ma vie avec lui
d'accord maïka je vais mourir demain
c'est pas trop tard tu comprends plus
alors évident quoi aujourd'hui greg le
millionnaire aujourd'hui il est toujours
intermittents du spectacle il ya une
prime d'exclus que gérard louvin
diverses excusez-moi
1250 euros par mois
ça fait combien on ecstasy
marqué pour un maçon ont travaillé pour
bruit que c'est pour oui c'est sûr c'est
sûr que c'est le comble racing signe oui
mais oui j'suis con c'est un signe le
fait qu'ils soient masson et qui bosse
pour bouygues mais c'est vrai bien sûr
j'ai pas fait gaffe
il ya plein de signes en fait finalement
un cocon
vous l'aimez bien votre livre voilà
j'aime bien le versailles et déjà je
n'ai pas déjà gelé pleine crise ne veut
rien dire que je l'écris avec avec
quelques années en collaboration avec
catherine siguret qui a qui pour moi
extraordinaire qui a réussi à me faire
sortir des choses que j'avais pas
forcément envie de sortir non je dis ça
parce que marjolaine excusez moi de
revenir à marjolaine mais l'a dit
physiquement il me plaît vivre avec lui
c'est une autre histoire à moins de lui
greffer une cervelle franchement lance
l'armée sans qui je ça me touche pas
voilà je suis d'accord on est maintenant
de séance un peu partout voilà ça peut
pas me toucher à la 20 angèle excuses
ouais vous trouvez ça c'est un bac l ai
dit ça vaut c'est différent
vous le préférez dans la vraie vie ou
dans la villa ibisa à la vie hein qu'est
ce qui va être différent tout c'est
quelqu'un de vrai c'est quelqu'un de
bien et à ibiza il était pas vrai dans
la vraie vie continue à vous faire des
cadeaux oui oui oui quoi par exemple une
belle montre prison des fois né des
commandes et fleurs il est fidèle je
sais pas magnéto serge
vous savez pas pourtant des femmes elles
le centre ça quand même non elle me fait
pas trop confiance elle a pas tellement
confiance en moi parce qu'elle sait que
j'aime pas c'est quand même assez
coureurs et elle a du mal à me faire
confiance bah oui les films de cul
charge donc je savais pas s'il est
vraiment fidèle en fait non bah ça sent
derrière lui tout le temps sicilia soir
il va rentrer que du rouge à lèvres sur
les courts que jamais
je pense que vous achetez maintenant par
rapport à tout ce que vous avez fait
j'espère j'espère que les gens le voient
comme ça en fait vous ma conscience ma
conscience a beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui
beaucoup et je pense que pour vraiment
régler le problème définitivement on va
faire une interview excuses
[Musique]
greg afin de vous excuser que
diriez-vous aux candidates qui vous avez
menti
vous étiez vous étiez adorable et
j'aurais bien aimé avoir le temps de
vous connaître un peu plus chacune ouais
à votre tour c'est bien marjolaine non
non je le ne semblait pas la peine j'ai
fait le tour deux jours ça suffisait
tout à cambrai
est ce que pour vous excusez vous
demanderiez pardon aux femmes humiliées
par le concept de ce jeu je ne veux pas
que les femmes aient été humilié par le
concept de ce jeu parce que celles qui
ont été là c'est qu'elle voulait bien
être là et je trouve pas que quoi que ce
soit d'humiliant fin de mon point de vue
à rennes 10 milliards m quand même mais
moi je me voyais pas comme un coq parler
du voile islamique mais enfin le
lasallois mais les filles y en avait
plein qui était absolument pas
intéressée par moi qui se plaisait pas
et à la fin j'ai failli me prendre un
râteau alors pour 1 à rennes pour un mec
qui était censé à 30 pas cher dans un
arène s'est plutôt transformé allender
ses taux pour la nation c'est ce pas
enfin ça peut servir aussi est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous excuser auprès
des masses sombres l'image déplorable
je tiens j'y tiens à m'excuser pour le
coup de masse dans le teasing on a
demandé de tenir la masse comme ça pour
faire un parallèle avec le club de golf
ensuite voilà je sais tenir une masse
excusez moi très bien oui est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à vous excuser auprès
des trafiquants de drogue pour l'image
déplorable que vous avez deux noms
j'assume et je vais pas m'excuser je
pense qu'on n'a jamais une bonne image
quand on est un trafiquant
malheureusement vous êtes prêt à vous
excuser auprès des dirigeants de tf1
pour leur avoir menti oui oui mais enfin
je sais même pas si ça vaut des excuses
après toulouse ça y est il est passé de
la peau donnait la poudre aux yeux ouais
voilà c'est joliment tourné tu as bu et
insolite la prochaine fois
je vais changer la fin c'est nul est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à vous excuser
auprès des gens qui vont acheter votre
libre non parce que je pense pas que
jamais excusé j'espère qu'ils aimeront
et qui trouveront ça c'est agréable à
lire et qui comprendront mieux certaines
choses qui ont été dites
là ma vérité a été été dit voilà je me
suis impliqué ça m'a fait du bien ça m'a
servi un peu de psychothérapie en même
temps et déjà rétablies tu espères
défend bien et je n'ai aucune idée ça
pressait
tu regrettes quand même
[Musique]
sur eux
ce et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
in a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu